alors alain c'est ici que l'adp a pris à
nager effectivement comme beaucoup
d'enfants de la commune comme pascal
voilà m et le bassin n'avait pas cet
aspect à l'époque c'est avec émotion
câlins et pascal évoque la piscine de
leur commune comme beaucoup d'enfants de
saint branchs petit village du sud
touraine
c'est ici qu'ils ont appris à nager mais
à l'époque l'installation était beaucoup
plus spartiate
c'est un espace libre ouvert et en fait
l'eau c'était l'eau qu'on trouve dans le
ruisseau un peu verte voilà le fond un
peu glissant parce qu'ils avaient de la
moussaye ont nagé au milieu des vairons
et des pétards malgré tout le lieu était
très apprécié des familles sur cette
photo je suis avec mes parents je dois
avoir 5 ans 6 ans et ma grand mère et
donc c'était une journée passée en
famille et on venait à la piscine pour
avoir un cadre agréable
comme beaucoup de familles à l'époque
mais l'origine de cette piscine est plus
ancienne l'inauguration s'est faite en
grandes pompes avec le maire de l'époque
le 21 juillet 1946 aujourd'hui il ne
reste que peu de traces de cette
histoire car cette piscine a la
particularité d'avoir été creusés par
des soldats allemands à la sortie de la
guerre 40 d'entre eux ont été utilisés
en travail forcé on n'est pas loin de la
ligne de démarcation une quinzaine de
kilomètres voilà donc qu'il y avait
beaucoup de campements allemand
dans la région à l'époque faire
pleinement et donc c'est en
dédommagement que des prisonniers
allemands ont creusé ici une piscine
c'est une des hypothèses voilà c'est ce
qui s'est dit après ces deux là seule la
tradition orale on n'a rien trouvé des
cris et c'est ce que nous ont transmis
nos parents nos grands parents sa
construction a été un événement relayé
dans un tract électoral de 1947 faisant
publicité du coût modique de l'opération
pour la commune
mais trente ans plus tard ce qui était
une simple baignade municipal a été
entièrement reconditionné la maire de
l'époque qui était pharmacienne qui est
sensible à l'hygiène publique avait peur
qu'ils aient les cas de polio et a
demandé pour qu'on réhabilite la piscine
tout de suite c'est une de ses premières
réalisations et c'est là qu'elle a
acquis ce nom de piscine et qu'elle
était vraiment moderniser voilà où elle
est devenue une vraie piscine avec des
chauffages du bassin sûr pour certains
plus important avec des pompes tous
aujourd'hui cette piscine moderniser
fait toujours le bonheur de la
population avec le maire les saint
branchs choix réfléchissent pour la
rendre encore plus attractive
il aimerait aussi rappelé sur le site
son histoire si particulière